con restricciones subsidios o incentivos
algunos países europeos buscan ahorrar
energía en tiempo récord con los precios
de la energía disparados Austria planea
auxiliar parcialmente las facturas de
sus ciudadanos el proyecto que espera la
aprobación del parlamento pretende
proporcionar 495 dólares para los
hogares más pobres y con más de tres
integrantes reembolsar hasta 30 centavos
por kilovatios hora hasta el tope de los
2.900 kilovatios hora le costaría al
gobierno entre 2.900 y 3.900 dólares y
estaría vigente hasta junio de 2024 se
supone que esta es el incentivo para
seguir prestando atención y no consumir
demasiada electricidad al mismo tiempo
2900 kilovatios hora es una escala que
como nos confirmaron los expertos
realmente alivia a las personas
Grecia por su parte implementa monitores
para que hagan cumplir el estricto plan
de ahorro y advierte de represalias para
quienes pasen por alto las reglas
reduzcan el aire acondicionado apaguen
los calefactores recuerden Apagar las
luces de los edificios estatales para
que no desperdiciemos energía y no
queden encendidas a la medianoche
estamos pidiendo cosas básicas y
sancionaremos a quienes no cumplan con
la energía 20 veces más cara que hace un
año en Europa esto afecta la producción
de alimentos de Países Bajos el segundo
mayor exportador agrícola del mundo y
limita los envíos de frutas verduras y
flores hacia países como España
Marruecos y Kenia
en Francia entre otras preocupaciones
las fábricas temen que la ausencia de
gas les impida pasteurizar la leche para
hacer yogurt producir otros 300 lácteos
y desperdiciar miles de litros de leche